relax Mario Kart fans the portly plumber
is making his casting debut on the Wii U
in just a matter of weeks but even if
you think you were already a beast with
a blue shell or marvel with a mushroom a
slew of new features in Mario Kart 8
mean that even veterans could stand to
learn a thing or two and so here's our
rundown of the four new items in Mario
Kart 8 and how best to use them first up
is boomerang like the green shell it's a
projectile weapon only the boomerang
flies back to you letting you give
competitors a good whack on its launch
and on its return Plus you can use it up
to three times before it disappeared
into the ether giving you more chances
to hit an opponent it's a fine weapon
then but it does move at a slightly
slower pace than the green shell which
gives your opponent more time to dodge
it and you a harder time to line up your
shot yes those irritating pipe dwelling
plants and Mario's platforming anting x'
and now in Mario Kart but they're a
valuable addition provided you're the
one dishing out their own brand of
competitive goblin goodness once
deployed the Piranha plant is able to
gobble up nearby coins obstacles and
enemies as you drive near them
you're also periodically given a little
speed boost as the plant
chomps making the Piranha plant one of
the most useful offensive weapons in the
game if you're sucking particularly hard
in a race every so often you'll come
across the Crazy Eights powerup rather
than a new powerup in of itself is
actually a collection of eight classic
power-ups like boost mushrooms red
shells and invulnerability stars
basically it's the Mario Kart equivalent
of neo asking for guns lots of guns
Oh unfortunately you can't select the
order in which the power-ups launch so
you never really know if you're about to
launch an attack or boost yourself off
the side of the track still think it's
stuck at the bottom of the pack
launching all the power-ups in quick
succession can wreak havoc on the
competition yes the super horn is the
much touted defense against the deadly
balloon shell however it's not exactly
what I'd call a common pickup and if
you're blazing away in first place
you're more likely to pick up a coin
than you are the super horn if you're
close enough to another competitor you
can also use the blasts to slow them
down or if you've got it especially good
timing you can deflect projectiles or
blast banana peels off the road that's
it from me but be sure to check out more
tips and tricks from Mario Kart 8 over
on games.com